Yeah,
no dude and cocaine.
Oh,
go back to that vest store,
man.
So here's what happened.
So I,
you know,
I would get,
I would do some cocaine,
it thousand put on these different vests.
I don't know,
I spent too much on them,
but I would probably say
the priciest one I had was probably about $210 90 damn.
Yeah.
And so I would get fucked up and put these vests on and put on sunglasses and
not met.
No,
like Buffalo Bill Shit.
But at least party and by myself,
you know.
And one time was making a smoothie,
you know,
cause I,
I have,
I've got like a new on what kind of blender it is,
but it was pretty nice and I was making like a nice smoothie and I'm fucking
coked up on party and you know,
live in high on the hog at this two vests on maybe.
Right.
And I thought,
I thought I heard something outside.
Right.
Which is kind of weird to even think of when you have a blender going.
So I'll leave out of my apartment to go in the hallway,
lock myself out with the blender going
during the morning,
coked up out of my brain.
I have to go to my landlord,
dude,
who lives right down the hall and tell him like,
hey man,
the more I got locked out,
blend on saying,
oh my God,
he must have hated you.
Oh,
the blender shorts out and smoke happens.
The fire alarm starts going off
in the building,
right as I'm ad is door knocking right now.
He's pissed and he's like,
what's going on?
And I didn't know what to say.
I told him that I was throwing a late Christmas party.
It was fucking into January.
I will with you at the time,
Huh?
Oh,
this is two and a half years ago.
So I was 30 35
so he comes back to my apartment,
right?
He's,
he unlocks the door.
There's nobody in there.
Oh my God.
I'm like,
man.
But that's it.
It was fun.
But it was,
oh my God,
that was fun.
You lived there for,
I still live there.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Passionate kind.
You know,
like I've caught him doing some things.
I think we're all even,
how long have you been sober for
year?
In two weeks.
It'll be two years.
What was the big thing where you like,
I gotta get my shit together.
You need that.
How it was going on.
Opie and Jim,
when opie and Jim Norton had a radio show at serious and it was actually on,
uh,
it's on Ari's,
that show that he had,
this is not happening.
Um,
and I ended up,
uh,
doing coke all night driving a taxi.
I was in a taxi.
The driver is dude,
Luigi,
um,
got me an escort.
I didn't want to ask or were doing cocaine and like Harlem or something North
Harlan,
the cabdriver doing coke.
And I just had,
I was taking a cab from a party to my hotel.
And so we ended up off on this other excursion.
Next,
you know,
I'm driving the taxi,
he's in the back with the hooker.
It's five 30 in the morning and I got to be on the radio station at,
you know,
six 30 or something.
So I get to the radio and I can't even talk.
And uh,
and Darryl strawberry's the other guest,
right?
Who's the baseball player who also had drug problem,
but he's like 13 years sober.
And so it was this weird moment where like,
I thought I was kind of cool,
but then here's a man who like,
I'd always in my head maybe somewhere thought,
oh,
that guy's like a coke head.
But then here he is eloquent,
put together successful.
And here I am,
I can't even talk.
And I'm with two men that I admire.
Um,
you know,
opie and Jim Norton,
just to be honored to be on the show,
you know?
And so I was like,
this is,
um,
I'm not making choices.
Like there's some,
there's some unevenness here,
you know?
So what did you do after the 212 step programs and 12 step program?
Yeah.
And then,
so yeah,
so I've been in that then since then,
it has helped me out,
you know.